hi i'm danny ceo and here's a do just
one thing on how to clean your brushes
now this is a toothbrush and this is a
hairbrush we all know that and you
should clean them because they can
harbor a lot of germs oil dirt and
bacteria
for your toothbrush this is the easiest
thing to do i like to use mouthwash so
if you look at a regular of mouthwash
it'll say it kills 99.9 of germs and
bacteria so what you don't want to do is
not clean your brush because if you have
a little bit of a let's say a cold or
something and you don't disinfect your
brush you actually can make yourself
sick again so so simple just swirl it
around and you're good to go and by the
way bonus tip if you are using mouthwash
and gargling with it don't spit it down
the sink spit it in your toilet because
it also will disinfect your toilet
second tip this is just water and we're
going to add
a little bit of shampoo your favorite
shampoo to the water just a few drops
and this is the soap that you need to
degrease
all of that oil and everything that's
gross on here off of your brush
and then we add something that is a
deodorizer and it's also going to be a
detergent it's just regular baking soda
right into the brush
and we stick this in and swirl it around
and what this is going to do it's going
to kill all the things you don't want
it's gonna degrease it
and in just a few minutes you're gonna
have
a brand new brush that's super clean for
more tips and ideas just go to the
drewberrymoreshow.com and be sure to
pick up the brand new issue of my
magazine naturally danny ceo now on
newsstands
[Music]